so this weekend though I'm watching the
Ravens game and I see this Best Buy yet
so I know that you love football but
maybe too much not saying it
not seeing it oh
defense
wins championships okay
let's go big
[Music]
the one spouse is confronting the other
spouse for being too obsessed with
football this not possible and this is
the kind of setup we've seen a million
times in advertisements and sitcoms you
know going back to the 90s but here it's
the husband confronting the wife for
being too big of a football fan and all
I'm saying is look I mean in the entire
history of sports going all the way back
through time to ancient times whether
they had their own sports maybe not
football how many times has a husband
had to sit down with his wife and
confront her for being too big of a
sports fan